こんにちははじめ社長です皆
夏は何が好きかな
とって女
それ俺だけどみんな夏はファイズが大好き
監修全種類混ぜたら何にゃんに
ああああああやっぱりと思っ
パコ部家庭で放っておきましたあのなっ
ちゃってやっぱりあいつの白いすごい多い
じゃないですかコンビニたくさんなくて
売ってないして片っ端から全部集めてき
ました102個か何やって100所で
集まったわけなんですけれども私 i と
思いました2倍も会津会はですね色んな人
や船帰っておりまして何を食べていいか
わからないんですね最近 no boku
no 氏はいた側椅子です何を食べていい
かわかんないです見てくださいまた100
周以上あるともうあすまんがかなり多すぎ
て中にはごまたまごみたいなチョコミント
までもいろんな種類ありますのバニラでも
たっくさんあります何食べていいかわから
ないこのためにですね私は今回全種類集め
て今から全部混ぜます全部混ぜると形で何
味になるのか私は気になりましたので
みんなを代表してこうやるの税務混ぜて
アイスの辿り着く月の先が何なのか調べて
いきたいとおもいますもう最悪だほぼ遂げ
たもう本当に回る自伝ネイルもて結構
飛び出てるちゃんと準備をしたっては
クーラーボックスとか準備でちゃん発泡な
んですけどもうちょっと圧好きで結構時
できてるねちょっと早急にあずみしながら
を全種類混ぜてねえ時になるのか見ていき
たいとおもいますじゃないぞ
あみ軽い
次早速混ぜていきましょうかといって全部
ポイポイまずでももったいないので
ちゃんと注意してから混ぜていきたいと
おもいます
おい尺処理君か今から
今日はったらもう時々誰が早速行き
ましょうまた最近の女神至っちゃこない
ですねこれやばい前に作ってる掘って
じゃあもうねーなーが今何をしたりしない
と思ってマッサージいただきます
4日おっ
まあないはうまいもんでの
味なんですよねでも入れちゃいます
ああああああ
oh no がピノいきましょーかいなあ
も昔からある子なら富裕なイメージある
けどなんか夏も売ってるんで歳っていう
もん
えっなんだ当てちゃって使うしていきます
できません
まあいただきますまあやっぱりちょっと
アイスって美味しいんだよねどれも同じで
産ませていただきます
見ていい中
湯切りなくこれも美味しいですよもう溶け
てるないただきます
うって皆よくで飛び書が俺一番多いと思う
これもせっかくに恋人してもらいます
ジャンボバニラもなか一時期はまってまし
たねああいう子のことになっちゃったので
もう溶けてるぜずますブーブーダミーが
患者濃厚な0
どこもなんかジャンボれは今も僕も
ゆっくりますいただきます
てっちゃんだよ
プーリーしゅっぱんちら何が夏といったら
コレみたいなところがあるんですよね
いただけます
ん
me
[音楽]
ブーブーいやあああっ
般若取ってきてくれ前お好みでぜひ食べて
みてくださいしてまではありません
以上読みたいマジで時出来てるヤバいか
これもばアイスバーから行こうかなガツン
とみかん何がきねっと多いですけど俺はね
食べたことないって実はこれこれを機に
すべてナイス食べるって事か元気だった
けど妄想
いただきます
思ってる玄関の引っ越しもビッグスイカた
御礼はをレイバーめっちゃ食ってた子供の
時いく中メロンバーガーもあるじゃない
ですかこれの女これそっちの方が好きだっ
たなぁいただけます
追加の盾になってるチョコチップがまずを
していん
がリゲルグソーダー子俺は焼酎の時はこれ
が趣味でしたからやって60人とかだって
いいじゃない何だろうちょっと上がってる
賢い60円でござったん
戦ってこれはいただきます
夏は春ぐらいなんかもう氷でいい
はも特切符ある麺もうこれはね味の高級感
が売りですから実家の冷凍品にパルム6本
立った時にこれ1日6個食いました親に
殺されかけました断面が美しいつを
いただきます
バニラが柔らかい形でくるの誰か良いん
俺はこんなことするパンフ2ぱぴこーんた
びっ子ももう姉2人で負けるって言っ軟質
よ意外と先っぽのここだけでいやもうこれ
はこの後また90
にょいいんだけどちょっと苦味があってね
めちゃくちゃいいパコ今やばこれもうその
あのあれああ
何ぞやんけどアイスボックスこの食べるの
もおいしいんですけどあれがおいしいね
コーラとかに合わせて音中に高麗でて飲ん
だらフルーティーだコーラが増えるという
もの感動でございますいただきます
うんありすぎじゃなくて動いてるとか
厚木 buffer これもうそろそろ
やばいぞこれそ2時間の問題だとこれ
いただきます
厚木バー
アイスキャンディーアイスたぐいまれに
見る大きさですよこんなに大きい
チャパティどっちかあさあ何かすごいなぁ
ブーブー言っちゃにょ
てょこういう現象が起きるんですよ逆に
これちゃんとこーっ暗い本美味しいから
あえてオレはちゃんを食べますいただき
ます
チョコ
えっちゃ
もうこんなんでください混ぜるで最終的に
剤と抗チョコ&ミルクミルク風味があって
これも度出すぞ何が違うんだろさっきのと
色が違うから何が違うんだと思います
エスパダチョコたっぷりでおいしいですよ
アイスがに恋分の一時期ハマってましたね
これもうおいせていただきますん
おまっ
会津のに濃いものを選びます
もうこれも合いそうに恋番号3いただき
ますうーんこういう番号うんブラック
サンダーアイスブラックさんなぁも2枚
入って負けますか
またそのお味はいかにいただきます
油区間だ
プレが利益ローズヨーグルトデザート形は
パルムみたいな
いただきます
んもぅブルガリアヨーグルト酸味が
しっかりきい最高大人の光軍ゴールデン
パインいやもう溶けてきてるの作画に
うわぁ気に入るだは不毛とも手でつかむを
やっとけせいただきます
まあ呼吸な試合でしたびっちょバッキー
大丈夫か本当にこれ超ソロ活動軍の気が
するけど皆さんモザイク処理させて頂き
ますごめんなさいちょっとも見せられない
姿になっておりますが味見だけさせて
ください開きます本来はバケバケのチョコ
が入ってるでしょ絶対 j は本当に来
たらこれ膳所ベロンとアーモンド入り
ブラックと毎年がタオルできるのかんっ
できたチョココーティングがされてる奴
って結構時に行く意味でありますね
になります
アーモンドや端っこ半分だ時はこれもう
吸ってるん
フルーツブラジャーしようとはうわぁこれ
節句低迷者物に行ったら
いただきます一箱待っておいしいよね
しろくまそもそも幻影があるかどうかが
問題 the 普段切りですいただきます
さんとめちゃんだ
あーもーやばいまず送る知るとも cup
これセブンで売ってるやつですね附魔装ず
ぎるでいただきますみかんと止めます
うんっ
これ全然ございますか
市場大好きなシロクマこれも7ですね苺
たっぷりのシロクマです本番前だろう
いただけます
さぶらふるーつ分たちは種族マ付録の多く
に種類だけ
んでしょっ
結構抑えて食ってるんですけどこれでも
だって3こんなサイズしか来たんですよ
ちょっとモグリっすねー
いますはつぶつぶラムにダメで椅子ば家族
で食べるようの大きいあいつは本会省いた
んですけどダメな奴はちょっとを実装だと
買わせていただきました1本だけ入れます
これは薄くせグリーンいただきます
うーんまぁ夏は氷機が5-5位新人です
書庫ば類
見たことないとまぁ時々しコロッケみたい
です
しますいただきます
まあなチョコがしっかりこういうのは
やっぱりが持つもしっかり打ってこれうま
いっすは普通で食べたかったアイスバー
ミニオンミニオンコラボのあいつバーです
よね広川いいなとも色入ってるいただき
ます
街がわかるんだよなさすがにもクリすぎて
味がわからんだよ
なんかよくわかんで桜子座椅子グラン
パーツ内装なかなか見たことに造られまし
た
いただきます
[音楽]
ブーブー大きいあー計算た犬4期なぁ検査
と入っちゃうとまた女なんか味に深みが出
そうですけどもはたしてその実態は
いただきます
もう線アイスバー姫が時で言ってて棒だけ
抜ける切りそうな始まってるもうやばいで
これ
山の付下履くとかついて大好評だった
いただきます
ビッキー
10分いてみようでまるでマスカットせ
名産ではもうこの3 f すごい人気な
印象はありますね私です
わートロットロに操るいただきます
を踏んまこれは人気でさすがにまるで完熟
卵もううんもうこれ完全熟してますねも
いただきます
ねマンゴーを入れてるですぐ藤堂になっ
ちゃうタイプ中身完全に溶けてももう
すごいと本まで本当に今の市場ってくれ
ました7家で生まれで完熟白桃ギリッは
もうすぐからも雨みたいになってる
これでいただきましたん
運命トロトロステルってもともとそれから
富山のまあもうもも入れてるみたいしまし
まうなばますまあがかなり色が濁ってい
ますであります
うん
なんかミルフィーユ状になって美味しいな
これベア java 6アイスクリーム
ダブル米アイスは見た目が最悪で買いまし
た奪いそう色がめっちゃ可愛いですになり
ます
じゃあベリーの味がすごいいや上手いし色
がかわいいなチョコチップメロンパン
アイスこりゃもう ic なのかごめんに
is とついていればアイスですやめろん
ばよな谷間生活まったりやっていただき
ます
meまあなんかメロンパンに中に美味しい
アイス増えてる感じでもこれなんかねーな
のか減っていなかったぜぎっしり満足
チョコミント僕チョコミント好きなんで
こういうのをしっかり食べたかっぱり村と
はいただきました ed 蕾です
いやチョコミント市長っていうのは web
負けてもチョコ3つの味すごいの俺様系し
てたアイス北僑胞ばっかともう時出来てる
スピードリーグでプロシンプルでおいしい
んだよな
ゴージャス
夢ゴールドミルク金時数はよく保ってると
よく保ってますよこんな暑い中いただき
ます
今うーんまあったのでピント大好きなん
だろうなぁ
さあやってまいりましたエースてる
スーパーカップバニラもうバニラアイスと
いったらこれは欠かせません誰しもが通る
道ですいただきます
甘い恋パンチラが定期的に食いたく別の
ドロドロドロドロ出来ていればいいだけが
難点ですよねセイバートップチョコグッ
キー4つか出て奥歯にらしいんじゃねちょ
も食べないせいただきます幸福ムっぽい4
瀬畑フッチョ込いただけます
味わいの深い地方民だ
ぎっしり満足チョコミントいただきます
食べすぎて足がわかったら美味しいですよ
めっちゃ
よしぎっしり満足チョコチップいただき
ます
[音楽]
府はもっと山れてっ
すごいついて気付きますみなさんなんか
無いさぁまた近々なんですけども今の一人
で来てくれると日和は下記521マジ
順番ミスっためこういうのは先に行くべき
だったよ
まあ
祭を感じるああ森永れん乳
しっかりとリストるん美味しいやん
美瑠喜
ソルティライチそれでちゃま一斉になり
いただきますソルティでしょうね
そう冷凍みかん広まって持っいただきます
う前桜でもビシャビシャイヤー氷が4件
起きてんだろうないただけます
僕はもう水水水水作例なしいただきます
部門
みぞれております
馬
北海道されに苺氷り
糖質50パーセント直バニラ s 大土地
を力これ食べてましたよいただきます馬
p 中古たちコーリー7アイスなので期待
値ががありますいただきます
馬
果肉たっぷり怨讐みかん calling
を待っ相談いただきますボンらっ北署生じ
ラブねえず
うまっ
ちゃんと東せていただきますいただきます
だからお酒の味がするらむねーずん好きな
人はこれあの20個送ってください
つば寧々家はれる calling ん
いやぁ何
年齢が入った
を中回復しタップ
であります
これでも練乳好きなんだろうなぁ
もう宇治抹茶その近くのコンビニもうの
バニラくそーのばならなかった
売れてるのかな
いやもうアイスじゃなくてます抹茶よって
あげます
[音楽]
昔なつかしアイスクリームいただきます
昔側から俺が子供の時の時代のもっと前の
奴なんだろうな多分
食べるぼくじょうみゃくしております
御供所
貯める北じょいちぼいております
ボブの以上食べる牧場メロいただきます
僕読めよ
ラムネソーダ馴染んできます
ラーメンソーダ味チョコバー来ここにきて
このサイズ渋いいただきます
と思う
やばいし抹茶になる全部美味しいのは
わかるんですけど食い過ぎている気がして
もお腹がいっぱいいすぎて感想が雑になっ
てしまうな道がご理解いただければ嬉しい
ですもうないねぇバッグ旅行北海道0
少しを食べたいいただきます
うん甘い攻めは空港北海道メロいやよくと
思ってるよ交通官がでよく登っており
いただきます
うん馬柄クッキーじゃない隙ありません
踏まえはもなおうち抹茶
うんをなお宇治抹茶チョコ早い税だけ違う
うん喜ばない j 101も贅沢
アーモンドも時間帯でこんなに寝室位は
変わっていただけます
うんあのぞ
能見地上マスカルポーネいただきます
なんぱるぽーねパンダアイスバーやります
うんファンととまたマイスマ遂げているを
いただきます
うん小川を思ってごまげだったちょっと
ごまたまごアイスになってる馬へ
卓球部保育さはいただけますホワイト
サワー papico まじか動画はでき
サンドやいただきますねうーん
アレキサンドルや
ああああああ
アップ例だろうゴディバチョコレートバー
があります
うんゴリがあちゃだゴディバ字綺麗に降臨
姉さんすごいアイス空けすぎると腕の握力
で開けなくなってくればいいですか親指で
力がいいんだろう
うわあああああ
[音楽]
ブーバースポーン電流ポール抹茶にポリー
ムーン抹茶ティラミスて氷チラ見せ効率な
ミスと交流と共存で
here ですけど果たして味の法案ん
てろ3-2はぁげっになりましたダッツは
もうなんか全部食べたことがなぜ分かるん
ですけど食べていきますクッキー&
クリーム
馬ストロベリー
奪えずバディダウン馬マニアだってうまい
mnet うん甘いひさちゃんの名分は
ミックスべリアのクリームを wish む
実況ふわぁもベースだわーバニラチョコ
ランバリアを張ったんだけど真花連絡し
勝ち
うわぁ
[拍手]
[音楽]
うん
4を
ごちそうさまですん
特徴そうですあいつ受けて無事にアイゼン
シュル102校要求の中に入れおりました
[音楽]
もう食えさすがにね102種類味見すると
ですねかなりお腹が膨れる市まつ毛がても
美味しかったんですけども内村から冷た
すぎて際はホ味がよくわからなかったです
からん皆さんこの中には僕たちが普段
食べるアイス全部入っています
より量が思って当てバイスって溶けちゃう
からそうと一緒に出してやったんですけど
水滴やばいまたしっかり冷たい容器に
入れる自然というか混ぜる時てて1回と
貸さなきゃいけないので必要な家庭でした
奴隷では全体的に結構飛び出る状態なので
混ぜます
ん
[音楽]
あどうぞどうぞ
ああああああ
はいというわけで無事にアイスクリームを
すべて均等に混ぜることができましたここ
からこれをどう会津くる意味するかという
ともう1回冷蔵しなきゃいけないんです
けどもこのサイズのほうの冷凍2の家では
無理なので今から巨大冷凍倉庫に入って
これ事倉庫に入れて冷凍したいと思います
じゃいかん
[音楽]
wh
というわけで冷凍も出来ました
[音楽]
こんな女が言うものを二段目とできん
マザーのそこまで言って冷凍させて
いただいてようやくや熊北家の近くの
for me などに浮いているアイス全
種類客にしてるよ混ぜて最強のアイス作り
ますさっそく見てみましょうこちら
[音楽]
大佐こんな額になってますもうちゃんと
しっかり凍っておりますなぜ音色はね
真っ白というちょっと本グリートいたら
感じでね
ちゃんとかた罰でアイスクリームになって
おります
日じゃあさっそく食べていきますよ
me
ことが来ました来ましていました来ました
来ました来ましてきました
こっちでも
[音楽]
で見て完成しましたこちらがすべての
アイスを混ぜてできた最強のハイする a
座さあ
gis aa オタが柱アイスエイジです
ねもうね味の見当はつきませんも本当
色んな汁だからまったく何味かわかんない
んですけど多分のチョコレートが多かった
気がするねそこが人かなんかカフェオレ
風味なキーはしますけど徐々に書いてみ
ますね
海外のお菓子屋さんのお願いしますで
チョコミントかニュイ強いな町民と匂いが
しますけれども味がちょっとわかりません
俺の予想はねなんやかんや言っても結局
バギーがたくさん入れたんでバニラが雑誌
つつも結局バニラ風味なっていう基本は
っていうなんかなぁ入れている患者が
チョコミント味強かったんでちょこみやー
いい意味でたなぁ
ハァー何時であじゃあわかんないんです
けどもなんだか色て気にはカフェオレっ
ぽい気がしますけどねぇメッチ作るの大変
だったんですよめっちゃ作るの大変だった
んであのすごい楽しみです
1個どっちを打たれなかったじゃああし
ないとこれ食べませんという意味で
さっそく食べたいと思います
いただきます
[音楽]
ん
いきます
んん
ていた
うんなんだこれ
なにこれなにこれなにこれ
あっはぁ
味と名古屋はからこれはずぶの上がわかり
ませんすよね皆さんただ不味くはないです
美味しいです友達に食べてるわけだから
美味しいんですけどやっぱんディナーでも
ない
なんだこれいやーこれアーチの例え方が
本店2お化けな国であるかな研究しすぎだ
背にいろいろ履き違えて曲がりに曲がり
ひねくれたばにラージュって感じですね
完食しましたよ普通に美味しかったこれ
1個以下た美味しいなと
[音楽]
うっうー
do俺はなかなかね俺はやりたかったけど
はなんかとてるし大変だなぁと思って体て
なかったんですけど最高の大きい要求たい
なということでようやく実現することが
できましたたくさん残っちゃったな
みんなああ